All right, so even though that
example that we just talked
about is something that
I drew up on the screen.
I decided I would actually turn
that into a real example and
ran it in Burlap with the implementation
of MLIRL that's there.
And this is the result.
It's actually kind of neat.
So, here's the trajectory and
the MDP that we ran in, and
here's how MLIRL decided to actually
assign rewards to the different colors.
So you can see that the cell
that's green is assigned very high
positive reward.
So it is drawing the agent over to that
that is a positive place to be and
you can see that the blue squares
are actually fairly negative.
The ones that correspond to
these blue puddles are given
a not insignificant negative reward so
they are actually avoided on purpose.
One of the things that's interesting
is as we talked about there's no set of
evidence in this trajectory that red
is good or bad and in fact it ends up
getting pretty much the same reward
as the background, basically zero.
One thing that's a little bit more
interesting is that it actually
concluded that this orange
strip is somewhat aversive.
It gave it a slightly stronger negative
reward to try to get it to avoid it and
I guess that was because the
demonstrated path didn't have the agent
spending multiple steps there and
it could have.
>> Yeah
>> But it didn't so
maybe it was a bad place.
>> Right there's lots of
ways that it could have got.
You could have come all the way over
to the origin going straight down.
>> Yep.
>> And
since it didn't it maybe try to
pick a path that minimized orange.
>> Right and so
it just kind of went with that and
gave it a slightly negative reward.
If we gave it a bunch more examples and
we could see negative
whether that rather than orange really
was consistently a good thing or
a bad thing,it would get fixed
with more training data but
it's pretty neat how much you can pull
out of actually one single example.
>> That actually that's
actually kind of cool and
I do like that gets slightly negative.
It doesn't believe that you're
trying to avoid orange just that
maybe you are because if you
weren't trying to avoid orange.
I guess if I thought about all the path
that could get me from where I started
to where in that up.
There's a lot of them that involve
touching orange more than once and
since you didn't pick that one maybe
you're trying to avoid touching more and
more than once and since are all the
same thing that would be evidence that
it's something to avoid although
it's only very slight evidence.
So that turns it into slightly
negative that's kind of cool
that's kind of amazing.
>> Yeah I think so too I mean and
one of the things that I really
like about this is the notion that
It's actually learning, not just from
the positive example of where it went,
but in a sense from all the different
paths that it didn't take.
>> Right.
>> Right and
so the fact that it didn't hit blue,
it used that as data.
So it actually is combining this notion
of your planning in the full MBP.
Well, we get to see one
trajectory through that, so
what is that telling us about
other parts of the MBP?
>> So
I guess the short version of this is
you can communicate a lot even
by communicating a little.
And an even shorter version
of that is less is more.
>> Well no I wouldn't say that at all.
>> [LAUGH] But you just did.
>> I did, but I did then I read it and
I realized that that's not what you
meant or that's not what I wanted you to
mean so yes that you can
communicate a lot with a little.
Less is enough maybe.
>> I like that.
That's like eight is enough and eight
is less the nine so less is enough.
I like that.
>> And that pretty much sums up the the
three Cs that I wanted to talk about.